und dann leute ist wirklich das
krasseste passiert was bisher beim
bachelor passiert ist ich war wirklich
viel geschockt als ich das gesehen habt
schaut euch an
[Musik]
meine sehr verehrten armen und herren
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
von bachelor in diesem video habe ich
gemeinsam mit ihnen das mir persönlich
große vergnügen auf die folgen vier und
fünf von labour zu reagieren ganz
wichtige formation für euch leute ihr
könnt auf tv sieben tage vor dem
eigentlichen release schon die neue
folge bätscher schauen link dazu sondern
der beschreibung liegt da drauf wenn ihr
das machen wollen ja was bleibt noch zu
sagen ich möchte nur noch sagen für alle
da draußen die ihre kindheit auf einem
einsamen bauernhof in lam pakistan
verbracht haben der bachelor ist ein
format bei dem 22 attraktive frauen um
einen ebenso attraktiven mann kämpfen
und dabei gibt es viel drama viel action
viel fun mit folge 4 und mit einer
kandidatin die ich zu sehen so dass wir
im zuge dieses wie es auch besser
verstehen immer weniger vieh leiden kann
ich würde gar nicht man sieht in dieser
schau natürlich einen kleinen auszug der
persönlichkeit aber es ist linda und
warum seid ihr jetzt
[Musik]
über getränke snacks für die geldpolitik
mit dem bachelor passau
das hat mir so imponiert dass sie als
einzige rausgekommen ist auch eine zeit
verbracht hat und nicht nur mich so alle
frauen gefragt hatte was sie trinken
möchten und ich möchte auch dass ich
weiß dass ich so was okay wartet wartet
wenn ihr euch jetzt denkt die gastlichen
nette aktion schlimmer war es ist so
leute ich habe schon mal eine ehrliche
meinung meine meinung ist dass ich in
dieser sendung sehr sehr viele mädels
und gerade linda weil die sehr
kompetitiv ist sagen wir mal gerne den
wettbewerb aus sticht jedes mädchen
sofort alle anderen mit dem knopfdruck
raus fliegen lassen würde wenn sie es
könnte und vor dem hintergrund hat das
ganze schon sehr so pick me weib so nach
dem motto guck mal ich könne mich um
alle so hey ich will gar nicht dass sie
anderen rausfliegen
ich will dass ich will gar nicht den
bachelor 50 mg haben ich will dass eine
andere als ich gewinnt auf jeden fall wo
leute falls euch jetzt denke ich noch
nicht dann wartet ab es kommt noch mehr
in diesem video dann hatte der
wirtschaft einen tag mit michelle lega
und der typ ist wirklich so ein schäfer
kleid des geisteskrank es ist wirklich
geisteskrank bisschen rip für die
anderen mädels sollte hätte ich dass
jemand im endeffekt geht es darum was
ich wobei der mann so darum geht es und
ich weiß wirklich auf jeden fall wohl
auf jeden fall zulassen
[Musik]
ich war auch ich mag ich hatte
unheimlich gern und ich finde gewissheit
machen so potenziell traum freuen
die also man muss sagen ja wetter ist
korrekt so der macht vier mädels
komplimente aber die mich gekriegt
wirklich das alles erfährt leute man
muss auch sagen ich musste da auch in
schutz nehmen so ich könnte mir auch
vorstellen wenn man so ein bisschen
introvertierte ist in manchen
situationen das ist voll schwer ist und
im fernsehen aus sich herauszukommen
problem ist ja dass sie nie auf ihn
zugeht und er die ganze zeit so obama
waren die komplimente hat diese
traumfrau der guard das wird sich auch
noch in dem video hier fortsetzt auf
jeden fall dieses thema aber so oder so
leute ich kann meine urteil aus dem netz
video bestätigen ich glaube ich glaube
eventuell ist michelle eine favoritin
ich kann leute ging es bewegt weiter und
das wort besser romantisch vielleicht
irgendwie haben wir so ein bisschen
atmen
danke dafür für diese art um geräusche
jetzt
red scorer der zweite kurs bamberg
stellt diese in dieser staffel und ich
muss sagen leute ich finde das war auch
ein guter wein so dass der etwa nice bei
denen wenn jetzt sehen wollen wie gesagt
schaut euch folge fiel dann auf die
volle und es hat einfach gepasst was war
chil ich finde steffi an sich also
steffi ist es jetzt zeit ist auch eine
chillige person so alles easy habe ich
könnte ja gar kein problem
auf jeden fall hat stellte ihren sperre
gewirkt engagierten auf jeden fall
seinen bann geschlagen was auch hier
war so auf
das restaurant sowie der soz riediger
das ist auch so wieder zu ihren
russischen vorab bekommen also fördern
die die methoden nicht ganz neu
entdecken am ende von so einer folge ist
ja immer nach der rosen und dann fliegen
immer ein paar raus wenn du halt vorher
russischen safestick jackpot
steffi hat eine bekommen hier fand ich
so muss ich daran gab es leider noch wie
floyd ich finde es ein bisschen krems
zuzusehen wenn die leute sich der fetzen
und im mittelpunkt von dem brief ist
linda ja also das thema situation
plötzlich vorwirft ich meine normale
computer sagt einfach nur ein kompliment
so alle machen dieser schon die ganze
komplimente weil du musst halt im rennen
bleiben so wissen da ist ein
leistungsfähiger macht komplimente so
auch versucht ihr auftritt aber okay da
hingestellt aber lindern kann so nicht
stehen lassen
erst mal vor versammelter mannschaft so
nach unten
[Musik]
bei süßen einsteckt bis brauchen front
ja also ok ok schreiben die kommentare
was ihr davon haltet die gabe in meinen
augen front nämlich empfindlich aber
wenn ich irgendwo jemand ein kompliment
machen mich irgendjemand nach wer an
dieser konversation also ganz beteiligt
ist dann ist das ein freund in meinen
augen
wenn wir diese fonds alter okay leute
man muss auch dazu sagen es passiert auf
einiges hinter der kamera so muss man
sagen vielleicht würde hinter kanada auf
dann nehmt das hier was jetzt gerade
sage mit klammern außen rum aber von dem
was wir sehen die ganze zeit am freitag
und so auf täglich so ich will auch
nicht zu krass gegen die schießen weil
ist auch unnötig wie niemanden hätten
aber das finde ich schon hart und
sympathisch muss ich sagen das geht
überhaupt nicht dann am ende voll zeuge
für sind ja leider auch wieder ein paar
rausgeflogen und zwar die folgenden
kinder
bucher
kim virginia oder anna wer bekommt die
letzte rose
das liegt jetzt vier auf rausgeflogen
anderer zum beispiel kann ich auch unter
dem strich führe ich diese entscheidung
ein bisschen ich finde irgendwie war es
schon so hervorgestochen beim rest war
irgendwie nicht so eine krasse
connection da so gefühlt zum bachelor
also kann ich verstehen
mit der entscheidung bin ich bin ich da
kommen muss ich sagen ich mache weiter
leute folge fünf das ist die folge die
eigentlich erst nächste woche im
fernsehen heute müssen die
fettproduktion rtl geben das ist uns
wirklich machen wie gesagt checkers
abliefern wenn er die ganze folge sehen
wo ich zeit mich hier nur ausschnitte
das ganze team also bachelor und mädels
in erstmal in ein neues haus gezogen
[Musik]
der stolberger da muss ja mal was man
noch urlaub so und dann leute mussten
natürlich das passieren was in jeder
bachelor folge diese staffel passieren
muss michelle macht wenig bis gar nichts
aber kriegt alle komplimente der welt
besteht sie auf meiner stirn geschrieben
dass ich gut finde
also so otto ist hier so offensichtlich
ja klar wir gehen ich bin trotzdem tut
mir halt auch wirklichkeit ich glaube
michael hat in manchen situationen so
ein bisschen niedriger selbstgefühl und
sieht das nicht ordnet das nicht so
richtig ein welche signale er ergibt
weil sie irgendwie ich weiß es nicht
ja ich bin kein psychologe aber
vielleicht glaubt sie nicht dass das
sein kann oder so ich weiß es nicht
genau und dadurch isoliert die sich
immer so weiter so ich sage euch ehrlich
wahrscheinlich genauso wenig verbessert
wäre wahrscheinlich genauso deswegen
kann ich voll fühlen aber es ist halt
wenn man von außen drauf haut nicht
optimale so
ich selbst dazu diesen satz habe ich
wirklich alle mit am meisten von allen
sätzen der becher gefüllt sind erst
einmal gefüllt ist also nicht so dass
ich safe ist aber er sagt aber auch ich
auch mit dem bussche du gefällst mir das
fand ich mit krassen sagt ich glaube ich
habe gewirkt auch ich werde ich das
nicht fertig
so denkt 110 den auf einmal er maß denen
sind dann nehmen so auf einmal das zu
krass das recht zur kastration stein im
brett ist es zu crazy und leute eine
sache muss ich sagen ich hab nämlich die
folge hier fünf habe ich gerade in jedem
vor diesem video noch geschraubt meiner
freundin wir waren uns eigentlich beide
eigentlich dass es sein könnte dass der
wirtschaft wirklich ein bisschen lost
ist wegen seiner vorgeschichte mit
michelle den man vorher schon mal
geschrieben und so wer weiß wie das
gesagt hat da ja nicht so interesse wenn
das von ihr ausging und er dann jetzt
man kann sie die möglichkeit hat sie
noch mal so zu bekommen könnte es sein
dass er das halt überbewertet so
ablehnung in der vergangenheit dann will
man es wieder wettmachen indem man die
person an hat so könnte tritt
designobjekt weil er im nachgang zu dem
date von michael geht einfach der
rastlos wirklich einfach straight hast
da wird einfach nur noch geld im
bachelor ausgeht dass hier
also der held der hält die leute und da
muss man noch eine sache sagt und zwar
habe ich ja gesagt dass ich mich schon
dass ich auch ganz sympathisch finde das
muss man jetzt ein bisschen in klammern
setzen weil die beiden mädels hier sagen
dass sie oder behaupten dass sie wenn
die kamera aus ist ganz anders sein und
das ist eine sache die man auch als
zuschauer von dem format nicht vergessen
darf manche leute manche leute sagen
dass michael das hat haben wirklich zwei
gesichter sind auf kamera so und wenn
die kamera aus ist und es mir darum geht
wie man beim publikum ankommen wie und
beim bachelor ankommt dann sind sie so
auf einmal ganz anders also mir ist es
halt besonders wichtig dass ihr auch bei
dem video so bisschen drüber nachdenkt
was vielleicht hinter den kulissen
passiert damit wir halt wirklich die
dinge so sehen können wie sie auch
wirklich sinn wer weiß was da dran und
dann leute ist wirklich das krasseste
passiert was bisher beim bachelor
passiert ist ich war wirklich viel
geschockt als ich das gesehen habt
schaut euch an
wieder ein kleinen liebesszene genügend
natürliche ganz ehrlich sollte habe ich
habe ich kommen sehen finde ich finde
ich richtig so habe ich kommen sehen und
da sehe ich die beiden auch drinnen so
in der beiden rolle aktionen gewissen
kreis an so favoriten wo ich mir denke
ja das könnte schon ganz gut passen ist
der mini michelle steffi würde ich da
eventuell auch noch mit 13 aber das hier
war fällig leute und danach ist wirklich
noch mal was passiert aber ich würde
auch nicht zu krass boylan leute aber
doch also ich will spaß so aber ich
werde nicht das rtl damit ist auch nicht
so schlecht
das ist bekannt
[Musik]
das ist ernst das ist wird das ist krass
das ist echt also ich muss sagen ich bin
relativ neu zu dieser bachelor welt ich
finde es richtig geil so das ketchup
mich voll aber ich habe mich noch nicht
so lange aus meine freundin meinte dass
so ein übernachtungs date oder so eine
übernachtung nur einmal pro staffel
statt finde ich weiß nicht ob das zählt
aber auf jeden fall sind übernachtungen
sehr sehr sehr selten und bei
übernachtung hat man natürlich keine
kamera dabei auch die möglichkeit sich
gegenseitig briefmarken auszutauschen
oder auch fotos von den süßen
schildkröten zu zeigen wenn ihr wisst
was ich meine leute auf jeden fall hatte
die beiden folgen waren richtig crazy
ich bin langsam wirklich wirklich drin
im tunnel ich bin jetzt schon halb auf
dem nächsten mittwoch wenn der folge
rauskommt nächsten donnerstag mache ich
dann die nächste patch erfolge für euch
also müssen wir jetzt leider eine woche
warten checklisten hier einfach ich
vorgeschlagen dass wieder um einen kanal
ich bin erst wieder raus leute macht's
gut